you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
how can you generate energy from hot
rocks we find out about a new scheme of
cools
eden project why the food on your dinner
table could be contributing to
deforestation in the amazon
[Applause]
and hitting the brace on an electric
future
mps warn our roads aren't ready for a
move to zero emission cars
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions now we talk a lot about
renewable
energy such as wind and solar on this
show but now
there could be a new kid on the block
drilling has begun at the eden project
in cornwall as part of a scheme to
produce
geothermal energy using hot rocks in the
earth's granite crust
to super heat water well in a moment
we'll hear
more from our science correspondent
thomas more who's in cornwall
but first what is geothermal energy
[Music]
so that's the theory and the reality
could soon be underway in the uk
at the eden project thomas more reports
to grow a tropical rainforest in the
cornwall chill
takes some energy and in the search for
a
sustainable
source of heat the eden project is going
underground
this 450 ton drill is boring nearly
three miles into the earth's crust
in search of hot rocks water that's
pumped down then brought to the surface
again
could be superheated to 180 degrees
that's enough to generate all the
electricity and heat that eden needs
plus more for thousands of local homes
the argument from those who are
anti-renewables was
when the wind don't blow and the sun
don't shine you've got a problem
now you haven't this will provide you
energy 24 7 when you want it
to fill in for all the other energy
sources so it's a a wonderful
triumvirate of power sources it's taken
10 years and
17 million pounds to get this drill in
the ground and it is that enormous
upfront cost that has been the major
deterrent to geothermal here in the uk
but the people behind this project
believe they can produce energy for the
same price as gas
but without the carbon geothermal energy
is widely used on the continent and the
costs are falling
but until the drill has done its work in
five months time
eden's engineers can't be certain they
can extract enough hot water
but the potential is so great they
believe it's well worth the risk
thomas more sky news in cornwall
let's take a look now at some of the
day's other climate news and millions of
uk
homes are at increased risk of
subsidence due to climate change
that's according to a study by the
british geological survey
it suggests drier summers driven by
global warming
will cause the ground under houses to
shrink and crack
scientists estimate almost 2.4 million
buildings could face problems by 2030
if action isn't taken
[Applause]
extinction rebellion activists have
staged a protest outside the science
museum in london
the campaigners want people to boycott
its new climate exhibition
as it's being sponsored by the oil
company shell
london science museum says it has a
complete editorial control of its
exhibitions
while shell aims to be a net zero
business by 2050.
scientists are warning that zombie fires
could become more common as the climate
changes
a report by nature found warmer
temperatures caused by global warming
allows these underground fires to burn
deeper into the soil
helping sustain them over winter zombie
fires can survive
cold seasons by smoldering in peat below
frozen ground
the fires then reignite when the weather
gets warmer
in spring prince williams announced
two young climate campaigners will be
joining the judging panel
of his 50 million pound earth shot prize
he says louisa neubauer and ernest
gibson will bring much needed
youthfulness
expertise and activism ernest told sky
news the project is an
opportunity to tackle climate change
head on we can bring together some of
the ideas
some of the drives some of the passions
from people all over the world to try
and find solutions to the biggest
environmental and ecological challenges
that we face at the moment
now the world's biggest food businesses
have all agreed not to buy
soy from recently deforested amazon land
but the bureau of investigative
journalism has found the amazon
rainforest is still being burnt
to make way for soya to feed the world's
livestock bread for the global meat
industry
now between 70 and 90 of the world's
soybean crop
is used as animal feed brazil is the
world's largest producer of soybeans but
vast areas of the amazon have been
deforested to make way for the crops
a practice that's meant to be illegal
but here in mato grosso
there's a problem fires are still being
set to clear land for new planting
and here you can see the fire at one
farm last july
now this is what that piece of farmland
looked like in 2008
and here's what it looked like last year
huge swathes of rainforest
completely destroyed well to help the
land recover
local agencies prevent anything being
grown or sold from the damaged parts
but it's claimed that crops are being
farmed in those areas and passed off
as coming from the adjacent sustainable
land
well the investigation found that this
soy is making its way into the global
supply chain from brazil to the us
the uk and china well with me now is
sarah lake vice president of mighty
earth a global campaign organization
that works to protect
the environment welcome to you um there
are controls already in place designed
to prevent the purchase of soil linked
to deforestation
so what does this say about the
effectiveness of those controls do you
think
those controls exist however there are
certainly large loopholes and we know
that a lot of the deforestation is
ending up in european markets british
shoppers are
unknowingly contributing to destruction
of the amazon through the meat they're
buying at their local supermarket
major agribusinesses are wiping out the
forest to grow soya to feed british
chickens and pigs
and even though these controls exist and
supermarkets are aware
that there is illegality and fires and
conversion in their supply chain
they continue to purchase from these
companies and we know that these
supermarkets could take action
they could cut their ties with these
companies that have illegality and
forest fires
but they continue to source from them
meanwhile as you mentioned
deforestation in the amazon is hitting
an all-time high
in the last year alone the amazon lost
an area over
20 times the size of the new forest yet
british supermarkets claim to take
action and we know these illegalities
continue
in the suppliers that are feeding
british consumers these meat products
so what could be done
well first we need uh strong due
diligence laws in the uk
to limit the import of products linked
to deforestation
but we also need stronger stronger
action from the private sector
from european companies and british
companies who actually show their
suppliers they mean business that they
will not
allow for deforestation to enter their
supply chain
so we expect that these supermarkets
drop
companies that are deforesting rather
than allowing them to continue business
as usual
even when we have irrefutable evidence
that
these farms are being cleared to grow
soya
sarah lake thank you the government
doesn't have a clear plan to phase out
petrol and diesel cars according to a
group of mps
the public accounts committee warned the
target of banning the sale of internal
combustion cars by 2030
could be missed and found the vehicles
are still too expensive
and there aren't enough charging points
and that's something the transport and
environment campaign group says is a big
problem
they've found that with sales of
electric vehicles set to increase
the number of charges being installed is
lagging behind
now this is how close different regions
are to having enough charges by 2025.
london perhaps unsurprisingly has
already hit its target
and scotland is at 82 percent but in the
south
east under half of the required charges
for the number of electric vehicles
are installed an extra 3932 charges are
needed
by 2025. in the northeast although the
region has 68
of the required charges installed only
an extra 395 charges are needed
by 2025 due to the lower number of
electric vehicles
expected in that area well greg archer
is the uk director of transport and
environment who produced that research
he joins me now
so greg archer the government maintains
it has a plan they call it
an ambitious and world-leading approach
to boosting the number of electric cars
so
are they on target or not as far as
you're concerned
government have a target but they don't
have a plan at the present time
they're relying on business to deliver
the number of charge points
which are needed and that means we're
getting a very uneven distribution
of those charging devices around the uk
with excellent coverage in some areas
and and negligible coverage in others
and if we're going to have a really
successful phase out of diesel and
petrol cars
we need to ensure there's comprehensive
coverage around the uk
so do you think that's one of the main
disincentives to people investing in an
electric car the fact that they can't
rely on those charging points
what our research finds is that in fact
the charging network is
better than people without an electric
car often imagine
but because of this very uneven
distribution people lack the confidence
to go out
and make the change to buy an electric
car
we also know the electric cars are
rather expensive at the present time
but we expect them to be the same price
as petrol and diesel cars
by around 2026 so that's only a few
years time
well the government says it's going to
invest money 1.3 billion i think over
the next four years to get the
infrastructure ready
what do you think needs to happen do you
think that's enough money is that the
issue
now i don't think the government needs
to be spending money what the government
needs to be doing is
coordinating the work of business to
make sure that we have charge points
across the uk
we need to for example get local
authorities to start to employ
charging officers who can start to
coordinate
to make sure there's enough charges in
their areas
we need to legislate to make sure that
car parks are actually equipped
with charges what our research actually
finds is that
two-thirds of the cars in the uk are
parked in people's homes they won't use
the public charging network much at all
the other third of the cars or half of
them will only need a top up charge
once a week so these cars don't need
a charging point outside of every home
they can go to the supermarket or charge
at work
charge at the station wherever they
leave their cars greg archer thanks very
much indeed
well that's everything from us for today
coming up tomorrow it's a classic summer
past time but
could pick your own be under threat from
climate change
you can catch that at the same time
tomorrow here on sky news see you then